شارك الاف الاسرائيليين في مظاهره لدعم
عائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في
قطاع غزه وذلك فيما بات يعرف بميدان
المخطوفين قباله وزاره الدفاع في تل ابيب
وقد قدم عدد من الاسرى الذين افرج عنهم في
الصفقه الاخيره قدموا شهادات عن الواقع
النفسي والجسدي الصعب الذي عاشوه في الاسر
وطالبوا الحكومه بالعمل من اجل الافراج
السريع عن جميع الاسرى في قطاع
غزه
معنا من تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره احمد هزيم
احمد اذا تتفاعل هذه القضيه تقريبا دون
توقف في المجتمع الاسرائيلي كل يوم هناك
وقفات من اهالي هؤلاء الاسرى واليوم انضم
اليهم بعض الاسرى الذين جرى تحريرهم
وتحدثوا ايضا عن ضروره الافراج السريع ما
مدى استجابه الحكومه وتفاعلها مع
هذا نعم محمود هذا التفاعل او تفاعل قضيه
الاسرى الاسرائيليين لدى فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه هي امر بات يومي هنا وضاغط
بشده على الحكومه الاسرائيليه ويزداد ضغطا
كلما خفت الحديث عن مساله الاسرى او مساله
التفاوض حول الوصول الى صفقه تبادل الاسرى
جديده مع حركه حماس وفصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه هناك في غزه كلما اشتد الضغط
من قبل هؤلاء على الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وكانت
التصريحات او او الهتافات في هذه المسيره
بانهم لا يريدون
ذويهم ان يعودون اليهم في نعوش وانما
يريدونه احياء وع على اسرائيل ان تقدم
الثمن للوصول الى صفقه تبادل الاسرى لكن
الموقف الرسمي الاسرائيلي الذي كان قد
اعطى بارقه امل قبل ايام عندما تحدث عن
عروض اسرائيليه قدمت للوسيط القطري حول
شكل وصوره اي صفقه اي صفقه مستق م قبليه
لتبادل الاسرى بعدما خفت الحديث عن هذا
عادت عا عاد الحديث عن الحرب والاستمرار
في الحرب والقضاء على حركه حماس وتحرير
الاسرى بالقوه العسكريه وهوما يرفض ما
يرفضه جمله وتفصيلا ذويهم الذين يقولون ان
تحرير الاسرى بالقوه العسكريه يعني ان
يكونوا ضحايا لهذه الحرب ضحايا للقصف
الاسرائيلي العشوائي ضحايا للعمليات
العسكريه كما جرى الاسبوع الماضي عندما
قتل ثلاثه اسرى برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي
وكانوا قد رفعوا العلامه البيضاء وخلعوا
قمصانهم الضغط المجتمعي على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وان كان يلقى رواجا لدى بعض
المسؤولين انما الاقطاب الفاعله في هذه
الحكومه اذا تحدثنا عن رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو تحدثنا عن وزراء واعضاء
الحكومه من حساب اقصى اليمين مثل بنفير
وغيره هم يطالبون بان تتخذ او يتخذ الجيش
الاسرائيلي كل ما يلزم لانهاء او القضاء
على حركه حماس والاستمرار في هذه المعركه
ويشعر هؤلاء بان الاولويه في لدى الحكومه
الاسرائيليه هي استمرار الحرب وليس
الاولويه تحرير المخطوفين وبذلك يستمرون
في التظاهر يستمرون في الضغط على الحكومه
حتى
ربما تسمح لهم الظروف بانتزاع موقف من
الحكومه الاسرائيليه قد يؤدي الى صفقه
تبادل جديده